[Music]
three two one action giggles thank you
he's a cool
I said gals hey guys welcome back to
off-the-record when we talk about
whatever way Wow today feels great
softest softest warmest most tender
hands look at the difference if I have
my hands are famously soft your ads are
yeah they're like what like damn yeah I
don't like hand we have time girls
sweaty Oh them but they are soft I felt
them I saw her hands are dry like if we
have to charge smooth if we had to
charge for like [ __ ] is you like
yours would cost way more than mine no
that wouldn't give the clan natural Lube
don't like to try hand jobs good right
wait what yeah well you got dry hand is
this legit er a bit oh [ __ ] I don't like
it
she gave me hand jobs and it's good I
just imagining I just like a light
basketball light dry hands I used to
like hand jobs anymore
no I'll come in like how many more over
the years I've developed this technique
that's better with by myself than other
it takes along I just have years of
experience I really have a [ __ ] than
a [ __ ] if you're if you're
negotiating you gotta if you can breach
would you give yourself [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
why would you ruin one of my song
rightness of a [ __ ] by masturbating
well it's Jackie because you have a dick
in your mouth
wait what's nasty when you have a dick
in your mouth in general or that the guy
has his own dick in his mouth
no it's nasty cuz I have a dick in my
mouth I just picture you right now would
you would you would you bust in your own
mouth that's what I'm saying because
okay so here's a point like it's like it
might feel good but at the same time I'm
I can't focus because the pre-cum is
going in my mouth gonna be a breaking
point where I'm like I enjoy busting in
mouths yeah but what I enjoyed if it's
in my own if you grew up busting in your
mouth that wouldn't you wouldn't mind
how do you grow up touching your wiener
ya don't have to bust him I think he's
just busting in your own face but it
feels I didn't know it was possible
until I saw this video yesterday okay I
giving himself a blow-dry it was a
pre-op trans and I wasn't searching for
this video you never are
I never I don't because the way I like
to enjoy porn is like roulette style
wait a minute
where that does nothing where do you
start this for me the front page that's
why it's roulette porn because the front
page is just like if you load it up it's
like the most popular or whatever's
going on right now right I don't
unless I'm feeling in the mood for like
a [ __ ] maid or something like I'm not
typing anything in the search bar how do
things even get popular like who are the
people that are it's probably trending
like cuber mine yeah it's like a youtube
recommended page no mine just kind of
goes based off what I've been watching
so it gives me normal [ __ ] cuz you got
algorithms probably she paid for the
premium what's you I'm gonna my friend
works at a porn company corporate side
and like he'll just fill me in on like
random that's all you have crazy stories
of that crazy ass friend I dunno crazy I
just say this is so nice my friend David
from high school he works in the porn to
you because I school with a lot of
interesting people
I did well cuz she's interesting to you
but he tells me like random facts about
porn like hey guess what the the
trending is now like the highest watched
country incest incest porn brothers and
sisters right like LM a stepsister
whatever and then also that sisters not
like it's like yeah some of you thought
I think I guess it's all incest
everything's [ __ ] incest dude it
drives me crazy
everything is incest though it's like
[ __ ] mom and daughter [ __ ] dad can I
just say to import like what it it
proper acting you don't constantly say
oh my god I can't believe I'm sucking my
own dad's dick every [ __ ] force for
minutes who says the [ __ ] in real life
ain't it stated over and over people in
real life who are sucking their own
dad's dick don't talk about how they're
stuck in their own dad's dick they just
do it yeah why someone stuck in their
own dad's dick they're like what are you
talking about speed right every country
has like different porn restrictions
like this country you can't show like
choking and spitting a lot of our [ __ ]
old JK skits would get like crazy it
would blow up huge cuz in India I guess
they're just watching that oh I'm like
interested yeah we're not even born now
one guy accidentally sent approved of a
porn to be sent to like Korea or
something and it was like things that
you're not supposed to show in Korea and
he actually sent a letter back with like
a red like official stamp and [ __ ] this
is you Bubba but you bring dishonor to
our country above all is somebody bit
like they're really strict about it
mm-hmm so wait when you're working at a
porn company like everyone at their desk
is look looking at porn pretty much do
you get caught watching it like watching
news you do it man oh no no I was on
porn I swear the [ __ ] news yeah
exactly yeah and I wonder what the
restrictions are cuz what if someone's
masturbating to porn and that's just
quality control or like or is that
sexual harassment cuz it's like are you
jacking off on the job
well his job was not like quality it was
more like to make sure I delegates and
goes to the right country so he has to
watch and make sure like oh this one has
spitting in it we can't send it to
bubble or this one has choking we guess
my god I would hear that job yeah right
can't watch a full porno anyway I used a
skip button you know when you were
saying that I pictured like sending and
picture like those old tubes that you
have to like
mildewed new incoming one he has a watch
few years ago I hosted the playboy
Morning Show for like a month right and
and one of the guys who worked there he
was one of the writers
he used to edit porn and he was telling
me that it just completely desensitized
because you're just watching it all day
and he was watching like dudes [ __ ]
each other and like girls [ __ ] each
other and just every single type of
everything and he said it like affected
his sex life yeah like a chef cooks
[ __ ] extravagant meals and then they
go home and all they want to do is eat
ramen right so I bet he was the guy that
just wanted to just pull his dick out of
his [ __ ] boxers and he's like I'm
done man I wish my job was to just
[ __ ] spend as much of other people's
money as possible so I can bet get
desensitized about - yeah I see I want
that dream - I want that job man I want
so much money that I get bored of it
that's a billionaires do their soul ball
and they just drive cameras they're so
ballin that they want to pretend that
they're normal people
yeah like Michael Jackson that's what I
don't get like Jeff Bezos driving like a
[ __ ] Taurus they all do that but they
probably have a hundred other cars and
Bill Gates cuz it probably have already
done been there done that had 300 cars
in LA ah [ __ ] it I'll just go back to
this dude Bill Gates wear the same pair
of glasses you got in 1995 oh they came
back into style they went out of style
another back yam jeez that's how old he
is I don't get it I'm like dude you
could you're Bill Gates you could spend
a million dollars a day I think it's
because they're not there for the money
they're addicted to what they're doing
rich
see ya my friends a mega millionaire and
he works a register and single you know
he's married with kids she please she
fight but he works he basically works a
register at a Food Fair what how cute
because that's my dream job I love my
eyes I want to be a checkout girl like
at a grocery store or even a teller
again that's just fun you could do it
any time no no I got responsibilities I
guys I mean if all my responsibilities
and bases are covered
and I'm rich as [ __ ] then I want to pop
I see that's what I would do if I was
weird [ __ ] it's always like crazy stupid
rich I would just take random
nine-to-five customer service jobs and
just what is wrong with you people
I want some rude
to come through my uh once I want a rude
[ __ ] to come through can I add to your
fantasy yeah I'm super [ __ ] rich as
[ __ ] to and I just want to sit next to
you and just hear it yeah right like I
will like I want to go to the middle
like suburban white country or whatever
and just like be the only Asian there
and I will sit there and I will wait for
a [ __ ] to get racist no one gets the
racist to you and everyone's nice as
[ __ ] you are the reason yeah because you
thought that they're gonna be racist
what happens though you're then you
bought your [ __ ] bank statement no no
you talk [ __ ] anytime to anyone but they
like use a thing I can talk a [ __ ] and
then they'll be like whoa I want to
speak to you manager all right come
through even if they fired me my only
have a [ __ ] I don't care if you Carol in
the place oh yeah like I own this place
they're like a secret shopper but that
secret secret worker I love that no
imagine telling a rude Karen like Karen
you're [ __ ] old no one wants to touch
you anymore your husband is cheating on
you that's why you can already do that
hired at Target and do that now and it's
come from someone who they think is a
lowlife register I don't still think
you're going to do that now and then
I'll go outside I'll keep their car and
get into my Bentley they're coming for
emotional damage Jeana they're not gonna
do that they're gonna be like she just
stole somebody's Bentley that's true
you're not getting one up on them no you
know what I want to do is just like it's
just I want to be a North Korean actor
like when tourists come I want to like
pretend to work at the grocery store or
like pretend to shop and like all that
stuff never seen that before
he's like scanning a vegetable no
barcode but it still beeps through it
makes no sense
North Korea they have all these like
fake simulated things work seems like
there's an active thriving community so
in tourists common stuff they they're
like look at this world it's [ __ ]
great and people are just walking and
pretending that they're playing and
doing that stuff yeah yeah they have
like computer stations where they're
just sitting there moving the mouse
around in circles
you want to do exactly what exactly you
want to be those people what are these
act yeah I want to pretend I want to
like look at the two real fungating
paint the regime on your back like you
want to know that you could die if you
do it wrong yeah exactly
you guys nobody wants to get rich and
just lay on a beach long after a while
you want to just [ __ ] work at a
bowling alley and polish the floor I
wanna I want to go to Home Depot and
[ __ ] on the fertilizer you can do that
I'll do that now but I have to work
right now to have money but when I do
all of your dreams are real except mine
well actually no mine's real too we can
all do it we need [ __ ] you money is what
is used on that club Hakkasan do you
know like my my career like the the
jeweler I went to my buddy's in Dubai
and something that his uncle owns
Hakkasan the story behind that is he
went to XS another club and they didn't
give him a table and he got so lucky
money yeah he got so pissed he opened up
a club club Hasan is it right next to it
it sits in another hotel I love that all
you guys just want to get revenge on
blue-collar workers I want to get rich
as [ __ ] so I could take shits all over
blue colored people I want to think
fertilizer yeah who's got clean that
[ __ ] up
no one goes back into the thing oh it's
senior anger at the right place that's
what st. that's what [ __ ] you money is
people are equally shitty whether it's
white collar or blue collar because you
can work for this company but it was
your choice to be a piece of [ __ ] to me
that day
no but [ __ ] you money is to say [ __ ] you
to the people in the tower yeah that's
what the environment for the people not
to kill it drive-through workers yeah
Thanks cool I like corporate people more
because he did [ __ ] them out of money
because he opened up one of the biggest
clubs out there yeah but I don't know I
want to relax too that's what's a while
I didn't get bored you will get more I
could do fun stuff at the beach by
trying to make the biggest slingshot
between two palm trees down what do you
do for the next 350 it's time to build
something like that and then you start
aiming it at like the random like the
whales and turtles no the one just get
out of Mac animals for ugly people what
are you saying you could build the
world's biggest snow cone geo that's the
second day sounds pretty funny okay then
okay now what about the rest of the year
you go trying to just eat hot dogs on
day three oh I could do this all day
make a sand castle Festival babby fit I
just don't harass you guys too
I want to arouse you guys and then give
you money after work you could still
harass us today I want to be able give
you money afterwards you all I'm sorry
yeah like sorry here's three million
dollars for blowing up your house I want
to build PTSD I want to build a sand
castle full of [ __ ] on the inside so
when that one freckle-faced kid coming
kicks it over he gets [ __ ] all over his
body nice dough see I want to open a
[ __ ] art installation and have
different dog poo from different
countries under glass you know to our
yeah watch itself for like a million
dollars I'm saying and you advertise it
and all the douchebag magazines those
have those glasses that you have to put
on to like look at Mt you have you you
have red wine flowing I want to start a
biker game that goes around and just
solely beats up races people is that the
Hells Angels
yeah because of your dreams our revenge
base yeah yeah yeah yeah or like or like
child molesters and something that I
just want cuz that you know like some
people like they get away or like
they're on the road and stuff I want my
people to find them and then kill them
hmm Alabama just passed a chemical
castration for toddler that's it hurt
they were I know it just passed it
Alabama please they're considering it
the consider
Alabama's considering chemical
castration for child molesters what if
they find out the guy like 30 30 years
later DNA evidence proves that he was
innocent
nobody thanks to this [ __ ] when it comes
to like stuff like that in capital
punishment I only support it if it's
like hard evidence like they saw you
with your dick in a baby's mouth you
know like you know like then you I think
chemical castration that's where you
can't refreeze into the balls and melt
the insides maybe I don't know that I've
been way more cool I think it's so that
you can't get hard-ons anymore some [ __ ]
no it's it's it's I think so they don't
they can't impregnate yes we can repeat
yeah reproduce but I I don't know I just
also think cutting off the dick would be
good is and that's what I'm saying
well it's only on people who are caught
red-handed yeah only on people who were
caught red-handed okay so so what's that
court trial now it's like whoa no we we
got them why are you gonna [ __ ] on our
dream no I'm just saying you have to
think about what this what that makes
not my job I want to come up with a fun
torture [ __ ] and then let other people
figure out a reasonable doubt by a jury
of your peers that's all you Americans
team oh man we got to be a little more
jovial
third world in here man dicks off and
people are in the news do you start
cutting innocent dicks off of it no but
if the line is here just don't even be
anywhere near the line and you never eat
something that sometimes it happens
where they give us a mixer against you
sometimes the guy is taking a piss off
the side of the road and now he's a
registered sex offender wouldn't qualify
in your perfect world exactly yeah yeah
for me because there's different levels
of sexual what is it what is this
tration all right that's about all those
different levels so like sexual
frustration is wild so if there's a guy
dude that was like caught raping chick
with DNA in her or like raping a baby
with a DNA everything the later you find
out she's a little person that's
actually 54 you know there's so many
ways around it you know what if you're
just peeing on an alleyway and a dog
comes elixir dick and then
say you're molesting dogs no the dog
licked his dick the dog people on it oh
no we gotta castrate the dog you have to
castrate the mouths of the dog for being
so good we go I would never evolve run
the government so many people die I
would kill so many people dude maybe
that's why Asian governments are ran
this way probably dude it was just us on
steroids
yeah I heard in Singapore like if you're
a political like corrupt person they put
you up on a plane and then just kick you
off with no parachute in China people
just disappear like in my country people
would just disappear oh yeah did Vietnam
did yeah they would interrogate you in
planes and then if and they would show a
guy's not answering and they're just
shove them out the plane and then they'd
get the next guy and line them up and
ask them the same question if that's
what it takes to cook good food I'm down
with a government like that what's the
connection go like in spirals up and
down is there good food in Asia yeah
okay draconian laws okay I see got it
win has free time ever brought you
quality food so now he explains it and
it makes sense
you guys chicken waffles is going food
chicken waffles is about as good as it
gets
yes I don't know I think if we are a
part of the rich and powerful and like
we're a part of the state all those
rules are awesome I wouldn't know how to
act it I would be such a piece of [ __ ]
this part of what you're not rich now
man great I would help people that's the
thing that's wrong though I spend more
money helping people but then at the
same time like if I could spend money to
to not help tell people I would
how come Germany doesn't have like the
best food on earth because there's been
like no more of that liberal no no no
I'm talking about like in their cultures
history so they've had like the most
[ __ ] up time start a to old war got
great pork knuckle see what's good in
Germany man I've been there had the beer
yeah schnitzel in Frankfurt with his
green sauce that was so good that was
good the sausage is on point those
sausages are pretty good schnitzel yeah
oh it's always like a cut there right
there sniffles are good too I'll give
you that that meets the meats are pretty
good but but not like all this is I can
only get this in Germany
sorry Germans I just don't feel that way
oh yeah feel that way about any European
food I'm a big fan of Europeans at all
French food I don't like sausages in
Italy that's wrong ago now well I'm
drinking monster you're not gonna make
it
I bet the imagination of wanting to be
rich is better than actually being rich
that's happened to my haircut lady she
became rich she was like hey listen
she was like no she's like all do your
hair cut but you you have to put on a
towel while you walk out of here and
just walk out of here some people don't
can't see your head cuz they'll they'll
think I do bad job and I was like
they're ashamed of you that's what she's
ashamed of her work I can't do much
she's like I can't do a lot so she's
like no but I mean you can't do like you
did not my fault it's his hair right
that's what I'm saying
do a mohawk everything my dear mohawk
that would work for me be amazing really
you think so well why not if you'd want
it at this point why the [ __ ] not I'll
do it for Nikki do it for Nikki all
right
[Music]
[Music]